psychologist marry at fee has been
living with her husband in a suburb of
Berlin for a year now Mary left her home
in Syria as Islamic state fighters
threatened to seize their town salamia
in the west of the country to indeedy
live in here in the beginning I found
life here somewhat difficult what with a
new language a new culture and so many
different people but now I like it here
very much hidden doshi ignition engine
oh yeah well it's this position furnish
back home marriott fee used to work with
disabled children she calls her for more
colleagues in salamia almost every day
she worries about the children the war
in syria has confronted millions with
death hunger and fear the emotional toll
is huge among those who've made it to
safety for example to germany many need
psychological help but there aren't
enough therapists who speak arabic and
understand the culture at the common
counseling center in berlin Syrian and
German psychologists are offering
further training to migrants with
experience in psychology or social work
so they can better help other refugees
12 Syrians are currently taking part in
the program I'm gusto dimension blink
Natalie know a lot of people we see have
gone through war and all those harrowing
experiences that come with us lots of
close family members homes jobs for the
entire world really for the most fun
albeit four limbs so something when we
have not to some of the people living in
the refugee hostels become severely
depressed or suffer panic attacks yeah
shirdi [ __ ] yvonnes and it's panic
attack on to tuna
the center has been receiving many
inquiries from clinics and other welfare
organizations that are keen to hire the
students once their three-month training
is completed marriott fee will soon
start an internship at another
Counseling Center she's looking forward
to working again she says she's not
frightened of the challenge it's likely
i won't only hear all the terrible
stories about the war in syria twerk i
already hear about them every day in the
news as a psychologist I want to try to
help people come to terms with what
they've been through it is at the same
time marriott fee is also homesick for
syria and the children she used to work
with